- Some people will also
discourage you and say,
"You know what, are you
sure you want to do this?
"Are you sure, you want to wait?"
Yeah, I'm not satisfied.
I'm not fully satisfied,
and I don't ever want to be.
I don't want to regret
anything in life, ever.
I do what I do.
I do what I love.
- Hello Believe Nation!
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe,
and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve all
of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn
from actress and
entrepreneur Deepika Padukone
and my take on her top
ten rules to success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really resonates
with you, please leave
it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it,
so other people can be inspired.
Might win a prize as well.
And also, when you write it down,
it's much more likely to stick
for yourself, as well.
Enjoy.
(swish sound)
(basketball bounce)
(uplifting music)
(stamp slamming)
Believe, you know?
Things will always not go your way.
There will be times
where things will be difficult.
There will be times when you wanted things
to be a certain way,
and they don't go that way.
But I think, through the years,
I think the one thing that I've learned
is to be patient and to really believe
in yourself.
I mean you can have,
you know, amazing people
around you telling you different things.
Some people really believe in your vision,
and some people won't.
Some people will also discourage you,
and say, "You know what,
"are you sure you want to do this?
"Are you sure, you want to wait?
"Are you...
"You know, why don't
you try something else
"or do something else?"
I think it's important to be...
I mean, at least, I fortunately had a lot
of clarity about what I wanted to do
with my life and for myself,
and,
you know,
I've been very patient through all of it.
And I'm not someone--
I don't give up easily.
- You just keep the faith.
- Yeah, I keep the faith.
I'd never give up.
The minute you tell me
that I can't do something,
I work that much harder to prove,
not to people, but to myself
that I can do it.
It can be anything.
(swoosh sound)
So every film
has its own challenges.
But overall, I think there is a perception
that the film industry is all glamorous,
and it's easy, and it's...
I think a lot of people feel like people
in the industry are very privileged,
but that's not true.
There's a lot of hard work and commitment
and dedication and sacrifices that go
into being who we are
or achieving what we do.
It's very easy to buy your ticket and sit
in a theater and watch a movie
for two and a half hours,
and be entertained or not
and that's totally fair,
but there's a lot of hard work that goes
into making that possible,
which I think only people who are related
in the film industry
in some way will know
the full extent of that.
(swoosh sound)
I'm extremely ambitious.
I know exactly what I want,
what I want to achieve for myself,
the kind of films I want to do,
the kind of people that
I want to work with,
and that will always
be an ongoing process.
Since childhood,
I've always known what I wanted to do.
Today, I'm living that dream,
but I always say,
I'm not satisfied.
I'm not fully satisfied,
and I don't ever want to be.
I want that hunger.
I want that motivation to keep me going.
- It's the hunger
that keeps you going.
- Yeah.
(swoosh sound)
Do I appreciate
and admire a lot of actresses around me
and people who've been around me before?
Of course I do.
In few films that they've done,
or in the performances that they've given,
or in the way that they've
conducted themselves,
of course I admire them,
but I do not want my career
to be like anyone else's but my own.
Because it's a very very personal thing,
and something that I like,
somebody else may not like,
so it cannot be.
Even if I want it to be,
it cannot be.
And I want to be remembered
for my own individual sense of everything.
Whether it's style,
whether it's films,
whether it's career graph,
whether it's
values that you stick by.
It has to be your own.
(swoosh sound)
- Tendency to be cynical
when actors go outside
of their country and work.
We've seen that happen
with actors in the past.
There's, you know, some people say,
"What's the big deal?"
How do you view it?
I mean, I know for you,
you've been staying around longer.
It's not like you're moving to the West.
It's not like you're
ditching Hindi movies,
and you're going to
completely move to the West
and become an American actor.
Do you see this as just another exciting
kind of stop in the journey?
Yeah, I think you want
to keep adding layers
to yourself,
to your life,
to your career,
I don't view them as two
separate careers anyway.
I think that's the biggest
mistake people make.
I look at it as one long journey
with different things
that could be thrown at you,
different challenges.
And how do you make them your own?
And, you know, I see
that people from China,
people from Australia,
people from England,
everyone's done it so successfully.
I mean, of course,
everyone's choices are individual,
and, you know, I'm sure
different actors have different ways
of how they want to maneuver their career
and what they want to do with their lives
and with their careers,
and it's also a huge time
commitment, you know?
It's not just about being in the movie.
It's also...
It's a huge commitment.
But I was willing to go through that.
You know, I was willing
to make that commitment.
I was willing to
tread this path
and experience this journey.
I don't want to regret
anything in life ever.
Eight years, ten years, 15 years, 20 years
down the line.
- And say that the
opportunity came,
but I didn't...
- The opportunity came
and "Ugh! I wish I did!"
You know, at least now I know I did,
and if it works, great,
if not, you know, at least I know I tried.
(swoosh sound)
- What does power mean to you?
And what freedom does
this power afford you?
- Nothing.
Nothing.
It means nothing to me.
I do what I do.
I do what I love.
The money happens to come.
It means nothing, you know?
And I know so many people
and my own experiences here.
You can have everything in the world,
but if you're not happy,
you can do nothing with it.
And it really means nothing.
So for me, if it's there, it's there.
If it's not there, it's not there.
It doesn't matter.
For me, quality time with my family,
going on family vacations,
spending quality time with them at home,
cooking a meal in my kitchen,
spending time with my friends,
being creatively satisfied with a film
or with a part,
being challenged in that sense,
going up on stage
receiving a Filmfare Award.
These are the things that
I really really value.
This makes absolutely no difference.
(swoosh sound)
- You know, sacrifices,
social sacrifices,
sacrificing I think for me,
my biggest sacrifice has been the fact
that I don't live with my family.
I've had to move away,
so of course there are days
when, you know, I go home.
I miss them.
I miss the fact that over a meal,
I don't have my parents or my sister
to talk to, you know?
Just talk about what my day was like,
or of course I can do it on the phone,
but it's different when, you know?
Your face to say it.
So there are certain
sacrifices that one has
to make, diet-wise, you know?
I enjoy eating.
I love eating.
Thankfully, I'm not someone who puts
on weight easily, but I have a weakness
for sweets and chocolates,
and I have to control that.
So yeah, it comes with its...
Or in the way that I
conduct myself, you know?
I think that is also a sacrifice.
If sometimes there's a certain way
I'd like to be,
I also have to realize that I have
to be socially responsible.
(swoosh sound)
You know,
as actors and as artists,
you're constantly looking for challenges,
either in the kind of role that you do
or in the kind of movie,
or like even when I did Cocktail.
Like, Cocktail was completely out
of my comfort zone,
and I think this was
the right film for me.
I remember being offered,
you know it's public knowledge.
Everyone knows.
- Yeah, yeah, Furious 7.
- I was offered Furious 7,
and we tried so hard to make that work,
and it didn't.
And today, when I look back, you know,
a part of me is like, it
just wasn't meant to be.
So, I always feel like
there's always a right
time for everything,
and I think that this, kind of...
this was just the right
time for it to happen.
And it was the right kind of challenge,
and in a right way,
I mean of course the character's exciting,
but I've never done this kind of--
I've done an action film before
but I've not done this
kind of action before.
I really don't know what
success means to me,
but I think for me,
to be truly successful is to be at peace
with myself and to be
happy with every day.
I think depression has taught me
how fragile my life is
or how fragile our lives are.
And it's made me value people and emotions
and feelings.
So for me, it's not the material things.
It's not the numbers, it's not--
Because there's always more.
You can be number one,
and then you will still want
to keep going at that.
Or, you know, you can be...
You know, you can have X amount of money,
and there's no end to that.
So as far as material
things are concerned,
I think there's no end to it.
You'll just, you know,
people want more and more and more,
and that's human nature,
but to be truly at peace with yourself,
and to be...
That's is success for me.
(swoosh sound)
- About a year ago,
I get a call from Paramount saying,
you know, they're casting for this film,
and I flew down and I met D.J.,
my director Caruso,
and then Vin found out in LA
that I was in Toronto,
and so overnight, luckily, I had a visa,
and he said,
"I want her to come and see me."
So overnight, I flew down from Toronto
to Los Angeles to see Vin,
and suddenly, in the middle of the night,
we're doing this 45-minute photoshoot.
Professional, with
lights and this and that,
and I was like, what is going on?
Because I didn't know if I got the part.
I still don't know if I got the part.
He just...
We just got into this
really serious photo shoot.
I don't know if you guys
have seen the picture,
and that was it.
- That picture right there?
- That's the one!
In his house, yeah.
- Yes.
- That's the one,
and he just put it up.
I said, "I do hope you know
"that if you put that picture up,
"it means I'm doing this movie."
He still didn't say anything.
(audience laughing)
He just put it up.
- And so, when that went up,
you got all these calls
from your fans and friends
congratulating you, right?
- Yes,
and I didn't know what to say to them,
because I had journalists
calling me from India
and saying, "Oh my god,
you're doing this movie?"
And I didn't know what to say.
I just, I was like,
"I don't even know if that's Vin.
"I don't know what you
guys are talking about."
(audience laughing)
- But I mean, or their
looking at it going,
"There's a romance going on."
That's what you would
get from that as well,
which there--
Oh, look at that face.
(audience laughing)
Does that mean there is?
Because that's what the rumor is.
- Well, there's no smoke
without fire, you know.
Look at that.
- So?
- But...
(audience laughing)
But it's all in my head!
You know?
- It's in his head right there.
(audience laughing)
Puttin' stuff in his head right there.
- (laughing)
So yeah, I mean in my head, I think, like,
yeah like we're together,
and we have this amazing chemistry
and we live together,
and we have these amazing babies,
but it's all in my head.
- Now you just became crazy.
I don't know what happened.
At first, it was a crush,
and now you have babies.
I don't know.
- Never a crush.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Meera Patel asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
check out the link in the description
and you can go and cast your vote.
I'd also love to know which clip resonated
the most with you.
What lesson are you going
to take from this video
and immediately apply to your life
or to your business somehow?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out
what you have to say.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Lauren.
Lauren, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book Your One Word
and making that video
on your YouTube channel.
I really really really
appreciate your support,
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed my book.
- This week, I read Your One Word
by Evan Carmichael.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(swoosh sound)
(basketball bounce)
- Everyday, every individual is
fighting a different battle.
We may not--
we all come to our work place.
We all meet each other
for eight, ten hours,
and we all laugh and joke
and move on with our lives,
but each one of us is carrying something.
You know, and it's important for us
to remember that.
We're all flawed in our different ways,
but I think it's important
for us to identify.
Like, for me, I've identified
what my strengths are,
what my weaknesses are,
and I've come to terms with that,
and that has made me a happy person today.
We should do what makes us happy,
what drives us.
If you're going to do something
that you're not interested in doing,
your heart's not there,
so I think it's very important
to follow your heart.
Every decision that I make,
and not just relationship-wise,
everything that I do,
including the films that
I choose to be a part of
come straight from the heart.
So, I think sometimes
people might question my choice of films,
people might question
various other things,
but I think at that point,
I'm just thinking from the heart.
(swoosh sound)